when you put out the notice she said
with peace and love I am telling my fans
do not send any motor you foot that I
love it
I know but that was one angry moment
please
after the 20th of October do not send
fan mail to any address that you have
nothing will be signed after the 20th of
October if that has a date on the
envelope it's gonna be tossed
I'm warning you with peace and love but
I have too much to do I found out
because I was signing and certainly I
would in New York actually over sign in
scratch plates that we have on guitars
yes and then someone said have you seen
me on the Internet
there's a guitar with my signature on a
scratch trade someone has screwed onto a
[ __ ] guitar right and it was selling for
three grand right because it had your
name on yeah I don't saying no so I only
sign for charity now right so mainly my
charity I'm Barbara's charity so if I
send you a letter with something to sign
you will toss it yeah I wrote it yeah I
know I listen if you say especially me